[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu veux faire plus tard
cette question j'ai l'impression qu'on a
entendu dizaine de fois la première fois
j'ai entendu c'est tout petit et cette
époque-là davantage j'étais capable de
10 secondes avait envie ils ont tous
aidé mes rêves ont tour à tour
je vais être astronaute jour de football
eh bien mon pied et puis en grandissant
on se rend compte qu'on se met à
réfléchir et c'est de plus en plus
compliqué d'y répondre
en fait le rationnel prend le pas sur
les lèvres
et là ça devient le grand flou ce grand
flou j'étais en plein dedans en janvier
je rentrais de six mois passés en
afrique du sud
et comme la fin de masterchef c'était
vraiment au bout comme tout le monde il
fallait que sur son travail et donc
france seconde pause a régulièrement la
question à l'ordre est grand qu'est ce
que tu veux faire plus tard et pour être
très franc
à ce moment là je n'avais strictement
aucune idée
il savait qu'à une chose c'est de
retrouver des litchis alors passé tout
comme ça
le stade je verrai à voir en chine un
grave ni gp comme une belle jeunesse paj
avait un colloque n'inquiète plus plus
bizarre je suis arrivé comme une fleur
ambassades
aujourd'hui mais apparemment les chine a
fait tous notre plan pour moi parce
qu'il va donner des visas pour les
stages payants oiseaux les gens
pratiquant je suis venu avec six mois
cambre point que le chien et vos côtés
je pensais avoir suivi toutes les bonnes
étapes ou par la troisième question
j'étais entrain dégâts de commerce
j'avais trouvé un secteur qui plaisait
mobilier jeudi spécialisé chez reebok et
essec de stage un baril à londres
je viens en process on va faire recruter
dans un des plans de l'actuel programme
est purement cherry bomb a et tour je me
suis rendu compte en fait que j'avais
mal quand il face à frouzins plaisait
pas du tout à qui je me souviens encore
de ma mère de lapin wifi zahedi boxing
oublié et là on se retrouve tous les
trois en 2014 à quelques mois de la
santé sur marché du travail sans savoir
quoi faire et en fait il faut savoir que
ronald fillon et moi on est potes depuis
plus dix ans on s'oriente depuis l'iss
est en fête et non s'est retrouvé une
soirée et on s'est rendu compte que les
mois précédents
on n est qu une expérience assez
similaire yvan et rodolphe da au chili
l'autre en garde à abu dhabi
gratuitement chez l'habitant
grâce au coaching et moi alors que je
partais moutet henri guaino sanaa avec
des potes
j'avais loué l'appartement d'un
particulier ceux avides et en fait le
point commun des aventures c'était
patins voyage restait les rencontres
qu'on avait fait
c'est ce chien avec qui il vend à la
part d'ingénieurs
c'est tout con des avec heroes dolf
avait découverte de son pays où cette
hollandaise qui m'avait accueilli à bras
ouverts chez elle
en fait en fait c'est tout c'est humain
retrouvailles à ces plateformes et qui
était replacé au centre des échanges
hélas pour la première fois en exil
intuition on a découvert un truc à la
licence on sait pas quoi honda veut
prouver qu'elles sont faits
quand on sait pas on étudie pour
comprendre on servira pendant une
semaine on a eu des bouquins ont eu la
presse on n'a rien des vidéos et plus
tant coup eureka pts on découvre que
hervier cacciari fait partie d'un grand
mouvement l'économie collaborative
mais son nom à l'économie collaborative
sait pas trop encore très connu et quant
à présent parler c'était essentiellement
en termes de chiffres de le mettre aux
entreprises ou de valorisation est
clairement c'était pas souhaité citer le
wall box qu'on voulait faire c'était
vraiment rencontrer des gens
la partie de la roumanie c'est l'échangé
stratégie des partis comme des vagues de
rona en or jaune et le vert avec de
belles de famille avec des références
d'heure des blogueurs de journalistes et
pas de problème on avait une règle
c'était ne jamais d'avant comme le mans
1 1 vers le mardi soir le stade de la
journée
un mardi soir deux heures
bleu avant on allait après que dans
cette dynamique là que les premières
ventes commencent à s'ouvrir dans le
segment là qu'on apprend assez ouverte
dans la bosse des cheveux la loi dit on
a rencontré jane russell est devenue la
la fédaration grosse parce que à
l'époque on me connaissait rien elle
connaissait tous les bouquins locales
ces personnes exactement on lui a parlé
déjà passé et elle nous a juste pris
sous son aile et en fait c'est grâce à
elle qu'on a pu être involontaire ou
sharp est qu'elle promet semaine est
camille collaborative en europe et ça
nous a permis de lever dans la semaine à
granby pour l'afrique mais ça m'a
surtout permis de penser des colis
collaborative et c'était tellement
inspirant au final le projet devenu
c'est devenu évident trouvent les verts
sont allés explorer les capitales
voisines et par ses acteurs donc on a
dit c'est d'ailleurs la première fois
cette fois c'est normal car de vancouver
jusqu'à rio sur un tamis km uniquement
dans l'économie valoir hâtives et pour
partager nous avons eu plutôt que de
faire mémoire de son père de nadia
on se dit aux gens que la montée
websérie le réaliser tous vos vidéos
cameron qui avait mélangé donc nos
aventures comment ça se passe quand tu
dis qu'avec et communales bourrative
avec interviews menton travers du
penseur des communes de syndicalisation
mais quand je me promenais votre série
en 4 8 secondes que cette version us du
service vidéo et un jour je vois cette
phase hôtel de ville il y avait un
événement
j'ai déjà payé plus grosse caméra et
j'ai juste aidé du baril s'est très bien
vendu je vais pas du projet se veut plus
j'ai essayé je vais j'y vais pas me
former les vidéos et le style vous avez
déjà posé pour toujours du problème la
série donnent aussi nombre équivalent
agit de matériel reste est du
collaboratif on a décidé de faire corps
val de grâce aux gains dans sa banque
avant l'été sur le site du luxe et des
biens sans bastille passif on l'a vu
petite description du projet c'est un
truc verrez qu'elle vit bien relou note
de synthèse a souvent heureusement vous
explique envoyé à notre spot a look
était consultant la communication vient
complètement tant que pape et
heureusement ça plus visible est sympa
mais aussi de la discipline qui était en
fait la mission qu'on s'était donné des
marges
et ça ça a été crucial ont fédéré
complète
et pour vraiment inspiré gens pour se
mobiliser et à partir de là on
commençait à nous contacter et d'actes
mende pour nous aider par exemple de
charles est très compact et qui est de
la connectique on incite les super
nouvelle attaque de soins du voyage en
asie voilà je vais paris jane vous ai
parlé de jaloux sépare les bleus de
claires références on croit vraiment
deuxième jeu balle 20,3 et validé samedi
un peu en fait la grosse et l armée et
les scénaristes à mobiliser autant de
personnes au sein du projet c'est un
parce qu'on croyance qu'on veut et qu'on
se donne à fond et peu c'est parce qu'on
a pas qu'on a osé demander là je pense
que c'est super important ne pas avoir
peur de passer moins cher parce que
l'énergie avec motivation c'est là que
les 20 secondes le 15 juillet 2014
c'était le jour du grand départ
direction vancouver
maintenant notre mission à nous c'était
de traverser la peau sénat américain en
stop en covoiturage et en dormant y
croient chez l'habitant
grâce à des sites comme barbie ou
ketchup et ça nous paraissait assez
simple assez clair mais une fois arrivés
sur place au coût de seulement 10
semaines on a réalisé que c'était très
très loin de gagner quand on arrivait à
vancouver l'état qui par quatre
canadiens dans une maison assez normal
avec quatre chambres
mais ce qui était beaucoup moins normal
c'est qu'on était plus de 30 ha grand
marché de ce soir alors ça a été une
soirée mémorable dans la considérait pas
que physique qui jouait dans la visite
du musée qui jouait dans le salon river
artifices qui exposait mais nous on a eu
des réunions à vous d'aller se coucher
levant le matin ou à l'interviewer
entrepreneurs impossible et parlerait de
la bulle les interviews savait pas
exactement comme prévu non plus la
première on accueille réussir au plié de
brancher un micro cravate on l'a fait
sans expression et ensuite pendant toute
la première semaine
toutes les vidéos filmées que la caméra
on n'avait pas été transféré la caméra
amateur
donc vous savez même pas ce qu'il mène
en parallèle pour chercher un courage
pour aller à san francisco s'il un
second stop vers c'est aussi l'échec
pour les cinq jours
ok on trouvera tout courage de trouver
une franchement à ce moment là j'ai
commencé à pareille stressé et jégou
forcément ce doux 3 la tension est
montée et inventée on a même envisagé le
fait de retourner à paris au bout d'une
semaine il fallait absolument qu'on
trouve un moyen de mieux communiquer il
fallait qu'on arrive à se parler et
quand les trois avec très pudique comme
nous c'est d'ailleurs arrivé en
béquilles un rituel sur lequel on peut
s'appuyer et ses rituels
ça a été la bougie la bougie c'est un
concept super simple mais qui a vraiment
changé notre voyage
on se réunissait tous les trois autour
d'une bonne bouffe au sarc désire
d'abord et après chacun son tour
on prend un total de parole alors c'est
peut être une bougie ou une boule et
riquet chabran fossé dubé et on va
commencer par dire les mercis la du but
c'est vraiment de prendre conscience de
ce qui se passe bien de détendre
l'atmosphère et c'est par plaisir
ensuite on aborde les problèmes là c'est
un peu plus sensibles et donc c'est
super important ne pas être posée
position d'accusation en dix ans mathieu
tu m'as soulière mais au contraire de
rattacher un ressenti personnel à un
événement précis dans ce mail
mathieu pour taper ça y est ça ma fait
la belle nous
blessés sont sentis un peu humilié il va
arriver vraiment se dévoiler et quand
vous arrivez à faire ça quand votre mère
pattie des voix la boue s'est retrouvé
sans idée et on sent sa très vertueux
chacun arrive a vraiment dit ce qu'il a
sur le coeur
là on va vous raconter ce qui se passe
pas bien on arrive à la troisième partie
s'est trouvé les améliorations
ça veut dire est très simple comme
commune à deux longueurs le troisième ne
prend jamais parti mais cette hausse y
est les efforts qu'on va faire pour
s'adapter à l'autre
rodolphe par exemple on a compris
catherine paul journet travail ce qui
fait vraiment plaisir c'est de se poser
avec la guitare tout seul et je la
musique et à ce moment là il faut
surtout pas que match et moi on a le
moral et pas devant les blagues lourdes
ça sert strictement à rien et grâce à ce
petit système la bougie tout simple mais
super efficace je vous ai toutes les
trois semaines environ
le projet va redoubler en sept mois
on a réussi à parcourir dans le 22 fois
la france sans jamais prendre un bus mis
un frein toute la nuit on va passer chez
l'habitant et quand ce n'était pas
possible d'aller toquer chez l'habitant
et quand même ça ça marchait pas on
préférait dormir dans la rue j'ai
d'ailleurs un en hôtels ou auberges de
jeunesse j'écoute a vécu des moments
incroyables
on est parti nager avec des requins
baleines avec un un chauffeur de camion
peu fou qu'ils avaient pris en stop on a
interviewé des entrepreneurs passionnant
comme le pointeur de couch surfing bagad
on a aussi eu des mots peu moins drôle
au costa rica
ça fait moins de caméras et d'un autre
ordinateur et au mexique
on a réussi à se retrouver en gros deux
stops dans un camion volé un barrage
policier un peu bâclé dépens en règle
est donné par tous pour un
et on a fini par baisser la violence
pour l'autoroute s'étaient rebellés
viseur mais tout simplement à chaque
fois on a pu les passer en forme et ça
c'était vraiment pas son esprit un peu
milliers et ça c'était pour moi le cube
elle prend tissage passé six mois et
voilà pour toute la vendée les ferries
cause ça fait deux mois d'aventuré sauvy
déjà problème ans puisqu'on arrive
quelque chose qui n'avait jamais été
fait auparavant les canaux de siècle
mais surtout parce qu'on est parti aux
débats cette intuition est en fait en se
donnant à fond
en tenant à 200% on a réussi avec notre
aventure et pour moi ce tapis d'algues
parce qu'à cette époque là le
département veut pas pour fonder
complètement perdu on savait qu'en
valais ont décidé de prendre des chemins
de traverse et sortir complètement city
battue et pendant longtemps on espère
beaucoup plus mais en fait place au
champ gauche on a justement retrouver
cet enfant nous a permis de vivre
n'aurait la faune y jouer complètement
épanoui ce qui aurait séduit on n'est
pas capable de vous dire ce qu'on a
envie faire dix ou vingt ans et une
souche qui est sûr c'est que maintenant
on connaît le chemin privé
[Applaudissements]